- I feel like I'm an official
Kardashian assistant right now.
Just lugging salad around.
(lively music)
- Hey guys.
I'm Sam.
This is Fernando and Alex in the back.
And we're in Calabasas.
We're about to try the
salads that you see on
Keeping Up with the
Kardashians, that all your
favorite Kardashian
women enjoy all the time.
They're always eating out of these
plastic bowls of lettuce, on the show
and we were like, we've
got to give them a try.
The place that they get
their salads from is called
Health Nut and it's in Calabasas.
It's about a 45,
half an hour minute drive from L.A.
- I'm personally excited
because they are filthy rich.
- Yeah.
- And they always have
all these great things.
So these salads have to be really good.
- Here we go.
- I think I like the look that they have.
It's very family, Thanksgiving.
Call me "Kam" and "Kenando" Kardashian.
Those are our new Kardashian names.
Just dropped over a
hundred dollars on salads.
- Alright, so we're back in the office
and we have a bunch of salads.
- Lots of salads.
We're going to go around and ask people
what they think of the
Health Nut, Kardashian salad.
What do you guys feel about Jenner family?
- They're cool people.
We love them.
- Can't stand them but you
also can't not see them.
- I'm indifferently
respectful of their careers.
- Yeah, I don't watch it but
I know that they have a show.
- Do you recognize this
salad from anywhere?
- I mean, it looks like a plate of greens.
- It does look familiar.
- I believe this is one
of the salads that they
eat very regularly in Calabasas.
- This salad creates a
Kardashian ass right?
That's what I've heard.
- I feel very nerdy that I know this.
Many of their episodes, you
see them ordering the salad,
eating it in Kris' house.
If you ever do a Calabasas tour,
this is the famed Kardashian salad.
- Ben, what do you think of
the Chinese Chicken Salad?
- It's fine.
- Oh my God.
This is delicious.
- I could eat this whole thing.
- It's really great.
- Pretty basic.
Could get this anywhere.
- It's a really good salad.
And the dressing's really light.
It's not very heavy.
- Can you see why
Kardashian, Jenner ladies
are constantly ordering these?
- It's got a lot of protein.
It's a salad, so it's healthy
and the dressing's really zesty.
- I think the bowl style,
aesthetically pleasing and plastic.
- My theory is they've been
going here for years, pre-fame.
- Only part of that life that
they have left to hold onto?
- I mean, you said it.
- I could see why they order it
because they're trying to
keep their physique up.
I can't see why they would
order this taste-wise.
- I feel like a Kardashian
with this salad.
- So that was a very full day
of Kardashian, Jenner salads.
Do you feel like you have gotten a glimpse
into their lives via vegetables?
- Honestly, every time I eat a salad now,
I'm going to think about it and think that
if it's not the salad we had
today, it's not going to be
the ultimate Kardashian experience.
- Yeah I lived vicariously
through a salad.
- The fact that when you're watching them
eat the salad, you know
what they are tasting.
- How many people can say
they experienced that?
- Not many and I'll say this.
I'm not a big fan of the Kardashians.
I don't dislike them
but I don't love them,
but after having their salads,
and realizing that it's
not a crazy-ass salad,
I think they're more
relatable and it makes me
look at them as real people
and not unobtainable objects
that people think they are.
(lively music)